please tell me such a critical
situation or we started to receive the first
message from Chechnya is that among the
mass retention of diets we
can go pop with us a spatula such a
close station is ready I have expired the term or
closed and more intelligence and rotation
is nonsense we have such Udege
and practically  immediately a decision was made,
but in order to save people to evacuate,
we didn’t have such experience, we need to
hide people, we need to look for them visas,
some ways of secrecy and export from the country
[music]
maxim very, of course, and add up
they will look for
it  I know everything perfectly well I will not do
everything so that it does not go out and pop up to
change the situation, only the person
who
went through these tortures for this publicly
will not do all kinds of actions
to shut me up
[music]